oh ma what are you doing today we're
working Network nah not anymore we're
gonna erase some rideshares
what so okay you know like it's like
late at night and you're like okay we
have to get home we have to call an uber
not at all but you always have the
debate of which one's faster which one's
cheaper yeah you have to compare both at
the same time and you have to wait a few
minutes because they both change yeah
they need the rig change I know that
yeah like the fluctuating oh yeah I
didn't know that laying on a little bit
of ground rules so we're gonna race from
our office all the way through the Santa
Monica Pier and you know Ally traffic
like getting from anywhere in the city
to like it's like a journey all day
hopefully on the way there we're gonna
take the lift and the uber X so like a
regular one and then all the way back
would learn to take a pool or a lift
line so that way we can compare the
economy they're regular ones and then I
would like to do the deluxe ones but I
don't think we can apply it next video
this is what we're gonna be judging so
first we're gonna judge how cheap they
are so we're gonna look at the prices
and see right away it religiously
cheaper and second we're gonna see which
one is faster so obviously the important
thing is you got to get them A to B and
you want to get there in a timely manner
so we are going to see which one picks
us up faster which one dropped us off
faster and then vice versa so the first
one down and back wins that challenge
last thing will be like it's a little
bit up in the air kind of like the
quality of the ride we're gonna rate
like does your person have water did
they have gum do they have an ox cord
because some you know what not all over
and lyft drivers are created equal I
think what's gonna work okay
although I bet wrong on the video like
this before I'm gonna say that uber is
gonna win because I feel like uber
classic you know the original alright
great right let's do it
I was doing like a No
[Music]
[Music]
so we're going to the Santa Monica Pier
and we're taking my price is $22 and 66
mine is $4 at one boom so still 11:35
John well you ready to order this and
see which one gets there first oh my
gosh screaming this way all right do you
actually have a driver is it saying
estimator where one minute oh crap okay
okay riding soon okay what's great oh
come on so are we were just arrived
immediately like exactly actually one
minute you ordered it so let's go would
be Ryan I am still here waiting just
because her ride got here first does not
mean she's gonna get there and also we
still out the lift line on the way back
so I might win
if anyone's Thursday just
this is bottled water there thank you
[Music]
looks like they're parking I can go
straight
I made it to the pier and it looks like
I made it four minutes before my
estimated time so that is four minutes
that goes to lips didn't get to the end
of the pier before them all does and
that way so we ended up my original time
was eleven thirty nine so they saved
three minutes versus our four minutes
actually for me yeah how much with what
was your so now she's gonna be a real
race on the way back that's the thing
sounds like now we know but bonus points
for and our guy was actually so nice and
he had a few fat with the puke emoji oh
wow he went a lot my guy he played
Whitney Houston and cyndi lauper okay
that's pretty me so that was fun yeah
but you know what since we're here we
should just stop for lunch though yeah
we'll do it okay so all the way back
we're doing share so you're gonna be
like on the fly so right now my chips
are here back to the office is 1840
[Music]
[Applause]
one to another well I'm gonna go ahead
order my way
[Music]
I did beat em all coming back and she
has a shoot after this and I made early
so I'm actually gonna set up person for
her just to prove that I'm not a
terrible person and that there's enough
time when you ride with lifts that you
can do someone else's job on top of your
own
Amala mall the mall it looks like looks
like I've been on a winning horse yeah I
packed like 20 minutes before you
literally did I set up is that okay I
had time both of my drivers were cool
boy it was just like quiet rides now
they're gonna have water gum really so
in terms of the race it looks like lift
lifts one in terms of speediness both
ways and a caveat I feel like both of
these experiences were very specific I
mean like like I feel like lifts can
have be have days when they are a lot
slower or more expensive and nubra can
have you know it's day-to-day but that's
true depends on what city you're in but
this is
[Music]